wants to try and hold off the rotations
oscar's gone chris isn't up still in the
picture oh still very much in the realm
oh chris he's found three it's down to
it two on two chris can he close this
with an x oh my god chris the wolf of
wall street gets an ace and it's
championship point mouse sports they
can't do anything more to like nerf it
you know because the gun's broken like
it is fully fully [ __ ] to think that
you can not be looking and just do this
and kill two guys he's like what the
hell man it's like it shouldn't it
shouldn't be fair oh oh my god he's
knifed him and he's gotten away with the
off i'm starting to get nervous
there's no way there's no way katie you
can't win pro league like this you can't
win pro league like this the op is a
feared and respected weapon in
counter-strike its mere existence
changes how players navigate the map it
is a situational weapon meaning it's
only used at certain times and places on
the map and he finds the start theory
unbelievable display there let's say
you're playing a game and your team is
just not using your smokes at all and
you're using your flashes and there's an
opera enemy team you're probably just
gonna get shot and now both back with
the angle there this should be
impossible from the way that's a nice
flick though but still with the 10
second he's got to find hobbit off to
the left oh
what is that flick from draken
hey folks before we get into the video i
just wanted to let you know that we've
teamed up with our friends at predator
gaming to bring you a holiday gift guide
so now i'm going to throw it over to my
close personal friend dimitri pasluda
who's going to tell you what he wants
for christmas
[Music]
alright so as the lovely dan rosen just
explained we have partnered up with the
homies over at predator gaming to slap
together a nice little holiday gift
guide for you all so sit back relax get
to know your hosts a little bit better
and maybe start feeling around for the
old wallet you never know you might get
some gift ideas of your own alright so
anyone who knows me knows that i am a
hardcore zowie stan who uses one mouse
and one mouse only
the za11 here's the thing though
apparently this new company vaxxy is
producing some truly e-gamer grade
clickers that are really starting to
shake things up the np01 in particular
seems like a banger hybrid between
zowie's za and ec shapes so i figured
hey why not try it out if i get it i
can't promise that i won't eventually
switch back to the zowie though like yes
the cable's getting a little bit heavy
but
it's the goat for a reason next we've
got something that many of you probably
have but i don't and really want a 1440p
monitor thankfully i found the perfect
one a predator 27 inch from their xb3
series it's
2560x1440 has 165hz refresh rate and
edge-to-edge screen space which i really
like i'm told you can check it out at
your local best buy which is probably
what i'm gonna do so have at it gamers
look it wouldn't be a dimitri list if it
was not being headlined by a cs go
cosmetic and this year i'm looking to
snag the only cosmetic that matters
a dragon lore more importantly though
it's the only s-tier cosmetic that my
collection lacks as the proud owner of a
gangneer a stat track fire serpent and
three lore knives i think it's high time
that i grab myself the goat anything
below a .15 floats is fine by me well
that's my holiday wish list thank you
again to our friends over at predator
gaming and be sure to check out their
27-inch xb3 monitor i know i will now
let's get back to the story
[Music]
thanks dimitri alright so the op has
produced some of counter-strike's most
incredible moments double smokes in the
same place they're simple just jumping
casually into the side he's gonna fall
down and get right down right what is
this platform simple are you serious
what is that you can't do that simple
that's not allowed this is not fpl this
is a major it's the only gun in esports
that has a dedicated role named after it
and operas are basically csgo's rock
stars well they're anticipating banana
from the looks if we got over over here
it's gonna be sideways it rings out
first
he's had enough he's gonna keep going
through it he doesn't really care about
it
[Music]
get him out of here
but what if i told you that the op was
actually a real problem for cs go the op
is present in almost every round played
both at a high level and a low level
most games see something with a pick
rate that high and consider nerfing it
but cs go has kept things the same for
years now valve has chosen to leave a
broken gun at the top of the game and
before you tell me it's not that bad
let's go over all the reasons it's
broken before we talk about why valve
might never actually do anything about
it the op has some pretty obvious
advantages but even outside of high
level play it's kind of insane if you
happen to be playing against a
disorganized team that isn't using
utility to knock you off of angles
you'll be pretty much unstoppable here
he comes once again the first base is a
trend he's gonna hit the ground there's
cold oh
how does he do this your opponents can
of course choose to just rush your
position and hope someone survives but
that generally doesn't end well keep in
mind this map can go t sided oh no it's
the rush up middle eco push
i did not want to see that guy since
that is that was tough that's like
watching adults beat up children operas
are basically csgo's angels of death and
lester dealt with quickly and happy even
waiting for the push and fallen gets the
spray shot anyway
what
what is that when they look for other
helpers for example you look for kenya's
you look for sometimes simple even
sometimes myself
we're willing to take a little bit more
of risk
and in the end you could be cut caught
in the process but you're challenging
the other team a little bit more so
despite the upcoming with some risks
it's become something of a csgo boogie
gun it's a high risk high reward monster
just waiting to end anyone who gets
caught in its crosshairs one player
pushes forward oh
as quick as lightning and now the 1v1
steadies the nerf sponsors
[Applause]
but the real problem with the ops
dominance is that there isn't actually
as much risk as you think it seems like
there's no wrong way to use the gun want
to play super aggro and demolish
everyone in sight go for it he needs a
multi-kill first found twist aggressing
they have to double peak he's getting
his shots he's hitting it
simple no simple that's unbelievable
prefer a more tactical measured approach
knock yourself out device that was
already down there good find on the
first one quick switch back over brings
out the safari mesh more and he gets the
second kill as well
losing fire power and advice ca sonic's
happy of that one can't decide which is
better just do a little bit of both he's
inside of this smoke he's trying to play
clever with this awp and he's got one no
no way kenny you gotta stop take it away
from him there's no way to shut him down
up close today now i don't know about
you but all of that seems pretty broken
even the pros can't seem to agree on
whether the op is reserved for
exceptionally talented well-rounded
players being an opera also requires you
to be to be good with other weapons or
if it can literally be used by a chip
it's very very broken and anyone can use
it so that's like the most annoying part
like you can die to the worst player and
you're like
he has an awf like it doesn't matter
and the question becomes even more
complicated when you look at someone who
isn't primarily an opera but still
manages to frag out with a big green
stewie's on his own but look at the time
look at the time there's seven seconds
of blood up
they're trying to build pyramids but
there's no more play
stewie's running around we're going to
overtime when you see players like that
it really makes you wonder is the player
just that good or is the op just that
easy to use to think that you can not be
looking and just do this and kill two
guys he's like what the hell man it's
like it should it shouldn't be fair
the fact that some people actually do
think that the best gun in the game is
easy enough to use that a child could
frag out with it might be proof that
there's a problem here but that's
nothing new see cs has been around for
two decades and the op has been a
fixture of the series since the very
beginning which means of course people
have been saying it's op since pretty
much day one that said it's difficult to
say how much of the complaining was due
to the ops actual problems and how much
was just people complaining i don't
think they have that easy job as people
may think and i think they actually have
one of the hardest roles because it's
also one of the
the most expensive role in the game and
it's not rewarding that much in economy
wise to have an opera but then again
this uh that opera can also change the
whole game and the whole round itself
and look love it or hate it the op
always lends itself to producing some
incredible plays it's basically the
coolest gun in gaming apex goes down as
well kenny s with no armor running
straight onto the side can he get to
safety he manages to get out the exposed
position picks up the frag onto aloo
goes for the quick second shot forest is
causing oh my goodness so much damage
down here by kenny yes another frank
found out again kenny s four kills in a
row at one point it was even a little
too cool valve saw the crazy [ __ ] that
kenny s and a few other players were
doing with the op and nerfed it back in
2015. to explain what's going on here
when scoped you now have a very slow
acceleration when running in fact when
shift walking you immediately start at
your max walk speed making it faster to
start shift walking than running the
optimal scoped movement then with the op
would be tapping shift to get going it
all feels really awkward but people
adjusted to the changes and it wasn't
too long before kenny was back at it on
the server so yes i had
time to adapt i was picking and shooting
at walls at the beginning because it was
a bit too slow for me but i
you know after a few weeks i was fine
you know and he's formerly known as the
pistol champion guardian goes down
flamie sue's next edward going to be
alone and he's cleaning up with a triple
kill despite all the nerfs the gun
remained revered there are plenty of
huge names in cs that are forever tied
to the op the big green has become
something of a star maker in the game
but that's not to say that the op is the
perfect weapon
all of the complaints that the op is too
powerful aside there are some things
that are weak about csgo's sickest gun
they get a lot of kills time to time
but they also get punished a lot like a
lot way more than people may think
because they always get smoked off
always flashed off they always have to
move around they always have to be
trying to be one two or even three steps
ahead of the enemy team to even get
their kills that they're doing and on
top of those obvious challenges operas
are usually under a lot of pressure like
maybe don't ask guardian about the
boston major final he cannot miss a
single shot
guardian waits
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
oh this happens they made it work cloud
nine are your e league major champions
but the problem is that the ops pros
drastically outweigh its cons the gun
basically defines the game so much so
that when valrant a game extremely
similar to cs go was released back in
2020 the devs felt they had to include
their own version of the op in the game
and people naturally thought the
operator would fill a similar role and
it did sort of the operator is very
similar to the op even sounds kind of
similar you know operator
even though the op and the operator are
essentially the same gun there are a few
crucial differences that make the
operator feel like a more fair overall
balanced option by comparison for
starters any cs go player can buy
flashes and smokes to counter operas on
the opposing team but in valoran only a
select few agents can do that giving the
operator a bit of an advantage however
the operator is clunkier to compensate
so the average player can pretty much
forget about quick scoping or flicking
the gun just works better for patient
defensive play rather than the flashy
aggro style we see from a lot of cs go
operas you wouldn't see something like
this environment because the op is so
slow plus the op is just like it's only
good for picks it's not good if you get
in a situation like this with a balance
you'll only get one kill max because of
how long it takes to [ __ ] in another
shot so while the operator might seem
like a more restrictive weapon it might
actually be better for valorant than the
op is for cs go the slow movement speed
of players invalorant makes the operator
really really strong when holding angles
but the slow scope animation makes it
really difficult to play offensively
with it sorry kenny s maybe someday
you'll find a game with an overpowered
offensive sniper rifle obviously valrant
is very new if riot really wanted to
they could turn the operator into a
perfect clone of the op but for cs after
nearly 20 years of pretty much the same
game that uses more or less the same
mechanics do you really think that valve
is looking at another game's more
balanced rifle and thinking they want to
make changes
cs go is a complicated game even
changing the price of one gun has a
cascading effect that basically changes
the entire meta it's a big jenga tower
tug at one piece and the whole thing
might come crashing down so even though
the op might actually be an over
centralizing problem for cs go it's also
hard to imagine what kind of game it
would turn into if you made the art more
balanced a lot of our strategies also
revolves around can the opponents have a
knob you ask the question how important
is it to know those kind of things and
the economy plays a huge part in what
things you can do can you run
specific areas without smoking net
smoking them or do you have to use a lot
of utility to get there i think they're
always very instrumental for
counter-strike
the ops legacy is undeniable it's the
one gun that showcases how even a flawed
piece of the puzzle can be crucial for
seeing the complete beautiful picture
that is counter-strike that's what dead
foxes could be on the other side of it
but he's straight out this time we
didn't see vampire races for a long time
and just catching dead fox in the hills
follows up well
get off just get a gun out someone fight
him someone do something stop it chris
how is he allowed to do this
and no matter what anyone thinks about
the op whether it's op or perfect just
the way it is it's already given the
rest of esports a benchmark for what a
truly iconic weapon should be
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our twitter instagram
facebook and tick tock